we mentioned to do that it's a privilege
to be acting and really the sad part is
the waiting around for the next job
right yes how do you deal with that yes
these the I always consider work
vacation and in between jobs is when it
becomes really work I I love staying
creative and fortunately because the
last exorcism part one was a success I
it's it's possible to to stay creative
um what I what I love doing I take
ballet quite intensely in between in
between jobs too it's always important
for me to develop a skill and learn
something new to give back I've taken up
ballet
I just want to point mootai it's kind of
a Thai Thai boxing
I've also stepping behind the camera for
my first time I'm directing producing a
documentary called love and bananas it's
a documentary about the rescue and
transport of two Asian logging elephants
from an illegal logging facility in
Cambodia to the Cambodian Wildlife
Sanctuary and that's been incredible for
me I'm born and raised a vegetarian
animals are a huge part of my life and
I've known about this project for I've
known about them trying to rescue these
elephants for ten years and when I got
the email saying they got them I said
I've got him filmed this I've got to
pitch this idea I teamed up with
production company called change for
balance we went out we filmed the first
go around we're going to go back later
in the summer and it's an it's
incredible to have a project like that
to be completely creative with and also
to give a voice to animals to those that
that can't speak for themselves
I'm sure it's interesting too that
you're able to sort of wear a new hat in
some sense because the glamour on the
makeup and all of that probably is take
second then then what the message you're
trying to say
yes apps absolutely um
well well you know 4 the Last Exorcism
Part 1 the scariest part of filming was
that there was no hair and makeup on
Saturday but yeah you know ferp I mean I
landed in Cambodia with the change for
balance team and within the first hour
we had cameras slung over our shoulders
we were walking the elephants through
the raw jungle there are massive spider
webs to my left there are a team of fire
ants trailing up trees to my right or
following these two huge elephants into
never-before cross jungle and I made I'm
climbing over trees I'm in mud and I
just I loved it I was like this is this
is it I mean this is talking about out
of your comfort zone it just it was so
much bigger than me I just gave it all
up and and kind of got embraced by this
massive world by by this magnificent
situation so yeah
you